comment gérer ça parentalité sereinement
prendre confiance en soi favoriser la
discussion les thèmes du forum bien-être
en famille qui s'est déroulé à
mantes-la-jolie ce dimanche était varié
chacun pouvait y trouver son compte en
fait avec ses intérêts en de parents
d'enfants de différents âges de
différents centres d'intérêts avoir un
environnement familial saint seurin
voilà il n'y a pas de notion de parent
parfait n'existe pas mais l'idée c'était
de donner des outils des clés aux
familles autour d'un jeu de société ou
en prenant une photo en famille parents
et enfants pouvaient se divertir
ensemble l'occasion également de
discuter et de prendre des conseils
différents débats étaient menés dans la
journée ce matin on a assisté au théâtre
forum
qui était un moment hyper intéressant
très enrichissant sur
la vie en famille les situations qu'on
peut vivre au quotidien de conflit
l'idée était d'un petit circuit une
esthéticienne juste à côté une coiffeuse
qui peut mettre en valeur déjà les
différents membres de la famille et puis
ben ali des sites et ensuite de
d'immortaliser ce petit moment en
famille et a beaucoup de créativité
il ya beaucoup de bas du coup de com en
parler des steam de soi rien je viens de
faire une photo ça nous permet en fait
de nous voir à quoi ressemble une
initiative qui répond à un besoin des
familles de se faire aider et guider
notamment depuis le confinement 15% des
français en télétravail ou infirmer que
les relations avec leurs enfants
s'étaient dégradées des actions donc
indispensable qui projette déjà de se
renouveler dans le futur